before we started recording Sweeney you
were telling a story of Sona had her
adorable dog with her oh there she is hi
Ruthie Ruthie I don't know okie oh okay
sorry no no how'd you come up with the
name okie you know my husband and I were
in Okinawa Oh honeymoon cuz when we were
in Japan we went to Okinawa for a few
nights and then we saw her picture on
Instagram and a friend of mine was
giving her away cuz she couldn't keep
her and so we called her okie to
remember where we were when we decided
to adopt her oh that's that's actually
sweet but so sweetie you did a cruel
thing to okie you know Kiev had a oh you
you had okiya in the office once I mean
oh he's an unusual looking dog let's say
what's that well he looks even different
now that or she sorry right different
cuz you you gave her a haircut yeah she
she's she's small and some would say you
know rodent like sometime yeah possibly
so she was in the office that I I think
I just turned to one of our producers
named Kramer and I was like oh you know
there's a rodent issue on this floor can
you have them look into this and I I
thought it was clear I'm sorry about
your dog so then like several hours
later I just happened to be in the
landing upstairs I was sitting in a
chair and these two men and uniforms
could come up there looking around and
they're like we checked the third floor
no signs of rodents they're like I'm
sorry fellows like well this guy Kramer
called us I don't think you're going to
actually find rodents no matter where
you look